in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Pete
and Rachel are with us hey guys how are
you hey Dave we're great how are you
better than I deserve welcome welcome
for you from Orlando Florida all right
and I'm heading down to Tampa myself in
the morning it's gonna be speaking at a
Bayside Community Church there this
weekend so get to see a little Florida
action this weekend good stuff so here
to do your debt free scream how much you
paid off we've paid off three hundred
and thirty eight thousand eight hundred
fifty dollars and 27 cents I love it
that's very cool and how long did that
take 35 months good for you and your
range of income during that time 222 290
thousand whoa what do you guys do for a
living I'm a software engineer uh-huh
and I run a small defense firm uh
yeah okay just like that yeah
understated I just got a feeling okay
Wow good for you guys and so uh well you
well you got the income did you do this
without selling stuff or was there
something sold or some kind of something
cashed out to do this so no real large
sales but the thing that I'll say about
Pete is if there is an item in our house
at any time or unfortunately on the side
of the road at any time you could win on
eBay it did and probably somewhere in
the several thousand dollars on eBay but
on eBay King yeah mostly junk literally
all right that's fine though it's cool
turn it into money a lot of Italy very
fun so what kind of debt was the three
hundred and thirty nine thousand so we
started out with some student loans
of course because we're normal um home
equity loan I quit a home right off your
house yes rather mortgage and everything
yes a rental property - yes oh my gosh
so everything is paid for every dime
Wow yes so what's your home worth about
275 Wow and what's the rental worth
about a hundred Wow
that's very cool congratulations you
guys so what happened I mean you guys
just like lit your self on fire about 35
months ago
oh yeah wild um so hopefully it wasn't
lighting ourselves on fire but we
actually got married 30 Oh
there's that okay yeah that we had both
kind of Pete had introduced me to your
program and both of us had sort of done
it but when we got married we just made
a commitment to ourselves in our family
that this was how we were going to live
our life and we're getting this mess
cleaned up the rest of our life to have
peace in our finances yeah yeah very
cool how's it feel you don't have any
payments it is amazing a nap yeah it's
probably time I'll say that I mean I'm
looking at weird people yeah y'all are
strange I mean you know normals broke
you everything your houses are paid for
yeah this is so cool you're awesome
you're heroes way to go you guys very
fun so what did you do to accomplish
this feat we we sold stuff then we could
just sell we really cut back spending
and and just anything we could find any
extra dollar we put towards that and I
think the bigger part of that is that we
work together and we worked as a family
we have three children in college and
working with them and then understanding
sometimes they go to Community College
first and then go to university and
things like that and just you know being
on the same page and doing this as a
family and doing it together and we've
had an amazing journey doing it yes yeah
it's been fun well very fun
congratulations what was the hardest
part of this process well for one again
we live in Orlando but I went out
without air-conditioning in my car for
about a year oh wow that's real yeah
you're making almost $300,000 a year you
got no a/c in the car that's that's
that's just weird
well I had the 240 air yeah so two
windows down 40 miles an hour right now
that's what mama that's what my mother
used to call it you know fortunately his
car has four windows only two of them
are Old Town dude you need a car oh my
gosh this is hilarious that's fun well
you can buy anything you want you'll be
able to save up and pay cash very
rapidly at the weight rate you guys are
Bennis amazing you have a fabulous
income
you'll be so wealthy it's going to be
unbelievable your generosity factor and
you're changing your family tree factor
and your college students got a lesson
in how to live life watching you - I
regret that they all are in school today
and could not miss because it was just
the priority but my daughter is our
daughter is such a little Dave Ramsey's
Ellie that you know every month at the
beginning of the month she lays out her
cash she doesn't like the envelopes
because it's too bulky but she hasn't
notes for each one of them and it's just
such a wonderful thing to see and it's
such a wonderful thing to see and all
three of our kids that they've really
bought into this and that they're never
going to have debt they're you know they
really are just on this path of being
debt-free for their entire lives and you
know how do I buy my house with cash and
that kind of thing so we're ecstatic man
that's awesome they're thinking
completely different because your
example well way to go you two very very
proud of you you're heroes we're going
to give you a copy of Chris Hogan's book
signed it's a number one bestseller and
retire inspired that's the next level
and let's go build wealth and increase
your generosity to the outrageous level
and you're gonna have a great life you
guys are so proud of you very very well
done all right Pete and Rachel Orlando
Florida three hundred and thirty nine
thousand dollars paid off houses
including the rentals and everything
thirty five months making two twenty two
two ninety count it down let's hear a
debt free scream one one one zero zero
one we're dead
Oh
I love it I even know machine language
you way to go you guys it's awesome that
nobody's done that before that's a first
very well done that's awesome man how
would it feel to have your house paid
off well you can ask Pete and Rachel
they can tell you hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
common